the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
let's look at this exercise
all right so we have this function is
even same one as before except now I'm
giving you this implementation if n is
positive and n has a roommate and
divided by twos remainder is 0 return
true so if n is even and positive return
true the next one if n is negative and
divisible by 2 return true ok so far and
otherwise return false question being
with that implementation is this test
set and it's 4 and is minus 4 path
complete and the answer is yes because 4
is an even number is is a positive
number and divisible by 2 minus 4 is an
even number is a sorry minus 4 is a
negative number and divisible by 2 and 5
would hit upon the else so the answer is
actually yes for that first question
perfect second question with that
implementation which value for n is is
incorrectly labeled by that program and
well and is very large still works and
is very small still works and remember I
said you have to test boundary
conditions in this case boundary
conditions for this program being when n
is equal to 0 so I think the orange is
and is equal to 0 perfect